fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby come on you're back you're
back in sandals and jeans huh where are
my toe holes worn those for a while no
you know some days I decide I'm gonna
free my feet you know what I mean I'm
gonna play these amazing pot uh sandals
on yeah flip-flops yeah they feel good
on my feet
stand by
no they look good and it's cold outside
a little cold outside a little cold when
it's raining when it's raining daddy
wears his boots I know I'm surprising he
just went sandals today I just sometimes
I just go I go I go let's do this and I
just slip into them you have to bleep
out that in the first minute chin I
picked up
all right remember I told you I tested
it it doesn't doesn't make a difference
no it doesn't make a difference it's
weird although YouTube has become what's
the word um about as sanitized as the
old TV shows oh you even look at uh our
boy just dropped a special and he had to
re-upload it he had to re re-upload it
no not big J big J dropped his eye is
today the fifth BJ's special go watch
Big J special uh dog belt just dropped
up today one of the funniest people on
the planet oh one of the best he's so
fast and so funny he's just so subtle
that guy is just a he's professionally
funny but his his uh yeah he's paid to
do it right his special dropped today
but um who am I what's his name the
young handsome bastard the young kid oh
um um Matt Rife dropped his it got
flagged so he had to take it down and
then re-upload why because Twitter wants
I'm not Twitter uh YouTube wants to make
it a safe space for everybody so if you
say certain words so now comics YouTube
used to be our one place you could go if
you didn't want to be on Netflix or
Comedy Central or maybe couldn't be on
HBO or Showtime you can go to YouTube
and get more eyeballs on it but now
depend on your joke they're going to
censor and suppress it so he had to I
think change a few things are you saying
that people in YouTube and other social
media companies are sensitive to words
to words yes
it's not freedom of speech on YouTube
anymore my man
yeah it's gonna get interesting because
for
I guess the route that sucks because
you're not getting new fans I was gonna
say the route to go is the Lucy K
version yeah Lucy K Schulte did but
schultzie still upload his to YouTube
but Louis CK's been known for a hot
second before all of us he was just you
could just get out Lucy there are no
there are new these new platforms like
Rumble and stuff are are well I saw Dave
Dave Rubin goes Dave Rubin goes I when I
was on YouTube before even I realized I
was Shadow bad I was getting about a
hundred thousand views he was now on
Rumble I'm getting 400k there you go but
that's also rumbles a very right fan
base so I prefer to say they believe in
freedom of speech not censoring anybody
and I think right now the rights over
there but the rights over there right
now yes no it's a right platform yeah
100 let's just call it what it is let's
not play that lane but that it's
definitely a right
platform now if they open up to more and
you're just allowed to talk however you
want great
I always say you know just it just seems
like if you have a point of view that is
counter to the corporate narrative the
mainstream corporate narrative you're
gonna get you need Rumble
yeah you need to run but you need
something else too you know yeah that
Rogan that shellenberger thing with
Rogan is pretty fascinating God that
stressed me out I think that what I got
from it was that Trump was Trump went
after the Deep state
and I remember I knew you're scared well
I I I swear to God I've never said this
out loud but I remember I know some
people who are maybe in the Deep state
or might be or know people in the Deep
state or in they're in that branch of
government and I I remember his wife who
was also in that she said she said
something to the effect she said
um he he doesn't know that when you go
that bad on the Deep State and you kind
of openly threatened them well you
openly are calling them incompetent
calling them stupid that they have ways
to get back at you she said that you
think yeah and my friend my friend who
was her husband said something like uh
yeah that's for sure something like that
that's all they said and I I clocked it
I remember I clocked it and I was like
it doesn't see this did your friend who
said he's in the Deep State tell you
he's in the Deep State because that's
the first roll of No in fact you don't
tell me it's funny you ask that question
that's very interesting you asked that
question because you can't do that so
they um if you met them you would uh be
told that they do something very
different the problem is that they're
always gone and the problem is they live
different places and they live in places
that I know yeah I don't trust them so
let me give you an example like um
my one friend was in a bottle
uh exactly for one year and then two
weeks later they they that's where they
got a Bin Laden yeah so that's where I
put things together and I went hold on
dude what are you doing yeah and then he
has a very different job but I don't
know what they do exactly but the point
is that I know that they know
I know certain things about it yeah but
it was really interesting to hear I
don't I don't think they're involved in
that but I think well maybe you said
they just know you out they just kind of
said that is that it doesn't end well
for anybody yeah it was too powerful
well but the CIA and the FBI there are
people who really did believe that Trump
was a threat to to our to our um to the
National Security to there sure but they
there were people who thought he was
unhinged and and crazy enough to do
something and I that that I don't know
that's not why they came after him they
came after him because he was you know
he was against the grain he wasn't
playing he wasn't playing their game I
would say there are a lot of
conservatives and and and that
organization there are a lot of
conservatives and Patriots I feel like
he seemed to be when he started making
Rumblings about there's a wild man yeah
because he's not gonna toe the line yeah
we can't have him that's why some people
love them and obviously he's dealing
with a number of issues now because yeah
you're seeing how this plays out with
the with the Trump stuff and obviously
got indicted yesterday
to me it's so stupid whatever is 34
felonies they're not felonies they're
misdemeanors right yeah so what they're
doing and I think this this isn't going
on for a while this can go into the
election next year so he's still gonna
be dealing with that it's clearly
clearly uh a play to mess up him being
the Republican uh yes president
Republicans
it's making them bigger it's making them
bigger for you know it just be very I I
don't think Trump's the you know
politics are [__] right now we we him
and Biden don't represent anybody right
the only reason you like Trump more than
Biden's because he's not your typical
politician right yeah he's definitely
many other things but what they're doing
right now you know all he's going to do
in some weird world let's say he becomes
president you know he can do this to
Biden and it's just going to come back
we're going to be dealing with this [__]
and it's nothing it's my that this isn't
making America better My worry is that
we are now a country that can prosecute
your political enemies and whether it's
a human whether you're on the left or
right you should be worded yeah I'm not
the biggest Trump fan I'm not the
biggest by fan I'm like any of them yeah
but when you can prosecute a former
president yes and for political reasons
later on later on I'm not gonna go I'm
not going into politics if that's the
case like nobody who's at qualified is
going to go hold on let's see I can
become the president and then because I
made political enemies I can get myself
in trouble but you should be more
worried about like we want your
president you want the president to make
the your the nation better he's going to
be so tied up in Revenge if he becomes
president yes and doing this to the
Biden Hunter Biden and then the fauci
yes you were gonna be dealing with this
for the next four years agreed that's
right that's also part of the plan
because a lot of people don't distract
us yes but a lot of what's really going
on a lot of Swing voters aren't going to
want to deal with that distraction and
that's that's the plan is to keep Trump
from winning that's all that's the only
reason they're doing this yeah and
that's that's for Republicans too they
don't want him in there and then when
fauci said there's only a pandemic next
year I guarantee it right around the
election just like
oh my God you're doing it to us again
yeah you're oh you're gonna leak it
again yeah right around the election
just kill me
how is it it's never been a worse time
to be involved in politics well I would
say I would say what I what I've enjoyed
watching with you is how you um have
become a political animal because you
had to be oh because we're walking
around like hey man shoes I got my
chains I got my cars and all of a sudden
politics comes to you yeah that ain't
you hey we're gonna keep your kids out
of school we're gonna do this and they
always be like hey [__] wait a
minute it's like a government how can
they do this you can have government as
big as you want but when it starts
interfering with my life man hold on
yeah man that's the issue it's not good
that's the issue and then what's even
scarier is you know Biden who knows if
they even make it to 2024 to run for
president probably gonna pass away so
who's up next of verse Trump
your old boy who's ruined our lives and
makes us want to leave California Gavin
Newsom yeah these are my options yeah
these are my [__] options
of a democratic super majority in
California there that when you have all
you all you need a mix you need blue and
red and you need to have them pushing
against each other when they're in in
their state legislatures and stuff
California has all blue all blue they
just like they just literally over took
it over with unions and everything else
so there's no pushback in California and
I think I don't know what we're gonna do
I think about California is now that
Silicon Valley is gone because they've
made it impossible to do business you
don't have that tax windfall so now
what's going to happen but we still got
sunshine in the movie in the in the
movie studios are out too because they
get better tax breaks elsewhere yeah
that's for sure I don't know what we're
gonna do dude we're gonna move to Texas
everybody
we'll see man everybody I know has moved
to Texas on the holdout so are you
I know I'm staying here I'm gonna wait
till properties like values I'm gonna
wait till I can buy a mansion for six
dollars
here yeah I'm gonna wait till this comes
Detroit and I'm gonna buy a house for
I'm gonna buy all the houses for six
dollars Chicago's gonna become I mean
LA's gonna become Chicago yeah but
that's okay the Chicago that just ran on
racism towards whites yeah hey what hey
yeah cool man Thai white guy they'd be
cool bro what the [__] well again it's
like he he was his opponent was a guy
who wasn't he was pro-choice but he but
a long time ago 10 years ago his
opponent said something to the effect of
um I am fundamentally pro-life but he
but he's in other words I'm pro-life but
I wouldn't impose on anybody else and
they kept running that and running that
and that's what one thing else because
white progressives are like oh wait a
minute let's take a break Brad can we
take a break take a break and I'm taking
a little break I'll be in Atlanta not a
break I'm gonna be working huh daddy's
gonna be working taking a break from LA
Live because I'm headed to Atlanta next
Thursday Friday Saturday Atlanta Georgia
Europe then after that it's La Jolla
Comedy Store June 2nd through the 4th
I'm jumbled across the pond starting
with Belfast June 15th you look up them
all over Europe uh UK London Cardiff
Dublin Manchester Glasgow and then I end
the trip in Dublin June 25th June 25th
one show only in every single City it's
a theater run so come get you some UK
England Dublin you know what I'm saying
tickets at thickboy.com Brian where you
gonna be buddy I'll be at the Helium
Comedy Club April 20th to the 22nd I got
Comedy Zone the vasani theater May 4 5
and 6 and then I got a bunch of other
stuff in may go to briancallen.com for
some some stuff listen man at the end of
the day sometimes you need a tuxedo
there are things as an adult you have to
go to I'll talk about this the other day
yeah and that's the way it is now you
can go buy a tuxedo for a fortune or you
can go to the black tux let me tell you
what the best place to go to man you get
on Trend top quality guaranteed to fit
tuxedos without ever leaving your house
here's how how's it work dude take the
black tux fit quiz pick the style you
want to rock boom your tux is delivered
to your door 10 days before you need it
which is plenty of time to try it on and
make sure it wears you well yeah but
what if it doesn't fit right what do I
do it's called the black tux fit
guarantee you order a better size within
a day or two of receiving no less than
great fitting one and they will send it
right away at no extra cost but what if
I don't want to do it online
has showrooms across the country they're
expert fit Specialists will help you
find the perfect style talks or suit and
make sure it fits just right yeah
sometimes I want to rock the tux dude
there's these fancy bars in La I want to
touch I want to look like a penguin rent
or buy oh dude it's the best place to go
when you need a tuxedo for a wedding or
special night right now you can go to
the blacktux.com fighter and use code
fighter you'll save 20 off your order
that is the
t-h-e-b-l-a-c-k-t-u-x.com slash fighter
code fighter to save 20 bucks the
blackstocks.com fighter code fighter if
I want the best supplements on planet
Earth tell me where I go dude I want
something good for my brain dude you
should know by now they've been with us
for over 10 years we're talking about on
it they if listen if you want to try the
best nootropic on the planet we're
talking about Alpha Brain it's all over
they've sold over a million bottles they
have so many ways to get Alpha Brain
into your big brain yeah you have
regular Alpha Brain instant jump into
eight ounces of water they have the
Black Label which I prefer they have the
Alpha Brain Focus shot some today just
now you take some Black Label literally
before this podcast Alpha Brain Black
Label baby do they have stuff for my
mood or my new mood Health yeah
melatonin spray that total gut health
which I swear by supporting daily
support dude they got vitamins for you
you got protein powders they got
creative essential nutrients they have
streaming Fitness if you want to stay at
home and get your workouts in then do it
with the kettlebells Primal Bells steel
Club Macy's quad maces yoga mats
sandbags they got it oh everything fit
to optimize your health everything if
you want the best nootropic on the
planet I swear by Alpha Brain Black
Label I like the focus shot but black
labels for your thick friend here go to
audit.com
f-a-t-k you save temperature
audit.com f-a-t-k you're welcome if you
want to get more depressed go to Sea
World
oh yeah I think my family to Sea World
and I I've never seen that Blackfish
documentary so I didn't you know I was
like whatever I'm sure they've changed
their ways and my girl wanted to take
the kiddos right and I was like can they
even have killer whales she's like yeah
look it up so I looked up she was right
they have killer whales but now because
those trainers died you know and then
Peta and all that got involved in it so
they have killer whales but they can't
get in the water with them
but they still make him do tricks and
[__] okay so they're so the only
difference is there's still a there is
still a willy the Sea World there's
still there's still a show yeah there's
still there's there's like two or three
still killer whales in they're big boys
and they said around the world they have
like 60 I think but they can't uh they
can't breed them so this is it but I go
okay what's your youngest one he's like
like 15. how long they live because I
don't know 60 years 70 years depends if
we take care of them like oh well
they're gonna be around forever dude you
think about the end of it to be gone I'm
like yeah but if you're gonna be running
this thing for the next 60 years with
killer whales and then there was one big
killer whale again I haven't seen the
dog before I went to Sea World and it
was a big one and we did the thing where
you eat lunch you can eat lunch next to
this the [__] killer whales and
they're like going around it's
depressing but the big one had his fin
like this that's not good right and I
went we had a we had a tour guide with
us I go you know we eat lunch he leaves
and then when we get we're like seeing
the seals or some [__] and I go hey
man uh quick question the big killer
whale in there he looked sad dude his
Finn was like this he goes dude do you
watch the doc I haven't but I know one
things they reference is that means like
it's depressed not doing well man the
biggest one in there is fins like this
he goes dude that doc just [__] man
that's just propaganda it's a sunburn
it's a sunburn it messes with the
collagen in the fin and then it goes
down I was like that makes no I didn't
say that when I went okay cool my head
is all that makes noise are there are
there killer whales in the wild like
that some of them but again they can be
sad too they think it's a depression
thing or you know but he says because
the collagen break it down the slope
drops off the slippers so if I'm
depressed and you say what's wrong I go
I got floppy the flop flop floppy flips
so then that was the first alarm like
that's weird but then the rest like the
penguin stuff they're thriving they have
like a frozen tundra the problem I think
with killer whales is if they're so
smart chin bring up an aerial view of
Sea World and bring up where the killer
whales are look at how small this area
is no I know that but that's what
they're saying so we go through the
whole thing kids have a blast they're
grabbing Dolphins bossy was way too
aggressive with the penguin like
grabbing his foot and [__] and then we
get back to the hotel and I go
hey you guys want to see something you
know I have my three seven year old like
I'm gonna put on this documentary on Sea
World like Yay fish see how small that
is yeah not terrible but um this looks
terrible no yeah that is terrible that's
a that's a swimming pool that they live
in but dude so we put on the black fish
documentary have you seen it be no dude
first of all I can't watch it it's awful
so first of all there's one uh uh killer
whale that was the guy from Canada was
notoriously known for being super
aggressive and killing instructors so
before it killed the big instructor I
think that was in Florida before it
killed that instructor it already killed
somebody up in [__] Canada and they
just shipped it down to Florida that's
like the priests yeah molesting kids
they're like uh you got to go down so
he's already by Nature aggressive and he
was huge too and then what happens too
is they're not in Canada they used to
lock him basically a cell solitary
confinement in this little cell so he
was super angry he's like dude I don't
want to be here so they send down to
Florida
he's aggressive already [__] up a
trainer but SeaWorld kept hiding it go
no the the you know yeah the corporate
[__] so then that one girl got uh
killed by the sea lion here's the thing
that sea lion sea lion I'm sorry uh
killer whale that killer whale before
this there was a guy who jumped into the
late at night I think he was in San
Diego late at night this same killer
whale jumped into the exhibit jumped in
the water was like swimming around you
know what happened to him no they didn't
tell you no oh he got his genitals
ripped off sir what yeah that killer
whale went what do we have here looks
like a little worm in the water oh cause
he was well that's your wee-wee he was
naked bit his dick off ripped his dick
off killed him like horrible death oh
killed him they don't oh dude hey you
rip your dick off killed him they don't
report that they say a guy jumped in
drowned they don't tell you how he died
that poor trainer that died dude prior
to this he was a super something and
show this trainer he grabs the trainer
by the leg and because he's pissed man
he wants to get out into the ocean he's
going under and keeps he would dive
under deep deep and this trainers he is
a veteran so he knew to hold his breath
and not fight it so let's do a thing he
come to the top and he was like
exhausted you're talking 30 minutes
going up and down [__] finally they
let him go they don't just I don't know
if he can suspend the killer whale
whatever they're like ah he's fine yeah
Corner that girl trainer well they
reported yeah she got mauled by the the
killer whale maltzer why don't you look
into it they said because she had a
ponytail they know you're not supposed
to have a ponytail well the ponytail had
nothing to do with it they have the
video she's sitting there and it grabs
by the leg one takes it under it doesn't
rip her channels off oh it Shank
Shank
scalp honk it pulls hers off dude
they're kill they're the Ted bundies of
the sea daddy pulled her scalp off
ripped her scalp off and when they did
the autopsy it was like ripped scalp uh
lacerations crushed her head ripped
limbs off bro every every yeah every
little well so I don't know if you know
this but that's a that's a is that a 20
000 pound animal six thousand but don't
say twenty thousand six thousand pounds
six thousand six thousand I think
they're bigger than six thousand no six
thousand pounds dude
it's a female adult look at the males no
but look at the mouse the females are
bigger than males oh please I don't know
about that dude I know my sixteen
thousand pounds Bubba
000 pounds
okay
okay now listen
listen you calm down no I'm saying the
ones in the sea world aren't that big
because they're they're raised in the
small by the way as if there's a
difference like no the one I killed her
is six the one that killed her was six
thousand pounds that's a lot of weight
yeah it's all but it's also they're
Savages they have no enemies in the
ocean well they 22 000 pounds heaviest
killer whale Jesus 32 feet long 22 000
pounds nothing's enormous yeah and and
but after after you watch that doc
you're like what are we doing what are
we doing and I looked at my girl I go
hold up I've never seen this dog I was
I'm a you know I'm ignorant to it yeah
but you've seen the dog you're still
Alaska to see her because that's [__]
up yep
I'll tell you I got caught in Riptide in
New Zealand yeah and I got was there
killer whale and a pot of killer whales
saw me
and I went
and they rushed you back in and no it
didn't do anything it just uh slapped
the water with its tail and it kept
dunking and then they all jumped over me
and then they formed a circle around me
see I like you're making the story a
little more exciting because you're
about to and they created bubbles
because you're gonna associate Sea World
with you getting trapped at Sea which
has nothing to do with each other I
appreciate you kind of blending it
blending which I appreciate they all
they all form these Bubbles and it you
wrote the bubble surface because I was
drowning and it washed me ashore and
then I went like this I went uh yeah and
they didn't rip your dick off they
sucked you no they they couldn't believe
my dick even in cold water but that was
more eel yeah no the but the other thing
at SeaWorld is when you pay for that
thing the food's awful the buffet food
is terrible yeah it's got better food
that depressed me of course my fin went
like this just from the [__] Buffet
the food was awful and then when we went
to the the sea uh no it's the dolphin
link to it they can't get in the water
with them they still they can't get in
water with anything no because they keep
people keep dying I mean Dolphins don't
get [__] they're smart Dolphins yeah
even then the trainers not happy they
just you could tell there's like some
weird like Sea World drama going on
there's just drama like well first of
all they're real short with us they're
like we need to break this up into do
how many do we have and she's like I
just told you yeah Fort groups we're
breaking a five she goes we don't have
five we only have four Dolphins right
and so they're like oh man this is weird
and then she's trying to do the dolphin
new tricks and she's she blows with she
goes uh whatever rexy's being difficult
today doesn't want to do videos keep the
animal that you have
keep the animal that you have we don't
have time for this I was like wow my
kid's like Daddy what's wrong I'm like
I'm not sure but wow and then they
[__] up and they allowed the rest of
the the people to come in because you're
supposed to have like this private tour
they allow them to come like let's wrap
it up we're there for three minutes when
you have
um when you are a Sea World trainer you
get into that you get into that so that
you can I'm guessing you can swim with
killer whales and dolphins like you got
into that because you want to be on the
top of their nose as they push you in
and you stand like that and everybody
claps some of them Just Do It For the
Love of the animals but it's in that
black fish documentary like that's what
I thought like my son was asking me he's
like Dad to be one of them because he
loved it Tiger's sewing animals like I
was as a kid we just bought lizards so
he was
do you like Dad have to go to school to
do this stuff I'm like dude you got a
major in Zoology blah blah blah tell
them like you'll do all the schooling
no man you watch that black fish
documentary the one guy was like yeah I
was like fixing brake pads and then
there's a sign to come to Sea World so
they seen um in the water with killer
whales he's like then I didn't know I
was gonna love it so much so I just
stuck around he died he died he died oh
he died oh he died sir yeah because that
killer that killer whale no because that
killer whale was killer whale that
killer well went because killer whale
Cannonball on him though on him yeah
true so you see the killer whale tuck
his fin like this and just Cannonball
right on his face yeah he died he died
yeah it's not gonna work out he died he
said he drowned they said he drowned
that's a lot of people the point is that
killer whale I was killing everybody
yeah this is where SeaWorld [__] up
they show and breed them so they just
get his big old [__] out and they just
stroke it like really man or there's
just a dude stroking it into a bag
that's not true yeah I promise they show
he's like laying on his back you know
when they call him like Hey and they
come up it's a big sea dick this thing
is a big sea cucumber bring up killer
whale no it's a big sea cucumber like
baby for reals this this at least this
long yeah this wide there it is that's a
[__] I don't know that's a real no no go
go that one like it looks like uh yeah
that's it that's his day see you they
thought it was the Loch Ness monster
[__] yeah that's like they didn't
unlock this monster that's a big old
Loch Ness [__] wow yeah so they jacked
that thing off and get the semen into
baggies now here's the thing that there
it is that big old cucumber there they
are jacking it jacking it hard right
here right that's from Blackfish that's
the actual there it is oh man so his
name's tilkum there you go that till
comes that [__] Ted Bundy of the sea
so tilkum they Jack them off Non-Stop
and then they uh got all the other
female killer whales uh pregnant with
his with his DNA the problem is is he's
the killer dude that'd be like it was
taking Charles Manson jacking them off
and then having all this Offspring
that's right so those other kill whales
are all seeds of this [__] serial
killer
killer whale well that's serial killer
killer whale was also made a serial
killer because of he the fact that they
kept him in jail well that too right
that too but then also he's just an
aggressive killer whale by Nature that's
what he's from day one probably yeah and
then they're showing what happens
they're showing what happens when he
introduced the the killer whales into a
new pod they get so [__] up they do
yeah man
this huge one he's like whatever ten
thousand pounds he's so big he was a as
agile as the females they take their
Dorsal fins and run against his tummy
and his bodies dude huge gashes ow and
they show his big ass jump up in the
crowd's like yeah
I was like oh my God like okay we have
to shut this down just blood everywhere
so when you see when I asked the same
thing those killer whales had marked all
over them I mean what are the [__]
scars from they go yeah it can be from
them going on the bottom and doing them
dude it's because
he's he's the new kid and the other guys
are going I'm going to cut you up with
my we're going to cut you up we're going
to Mark you up and this dorsal Fin's not
sad this thing is [__] razor sharp no
kidding and they can cut you with their
dorsal fin
yeah that's uh the whole thing was just
again now the kids had kids had to eat
blast you're talking about what kind of
animals where great whites full-grown
great whites if they even hear them
run and they run disappear great whites
great whites are like holy [__] no I'll
be I'll be transparent kids have a great
time okay at the expense of these killer
whales yeah okay Daddy in this family
had a good time well but it was very sad
once you know what's going on there are
they giving that away for free they're
not that's way cheaper than Disneyland
or some [__] like that that's crazy yeah
Disneyland's insane it doesn't give up
yeah trade your kid in yes yeah
Disneyland's out of control Sea World is
a good time and if you talk to them
they're doing a lot to take care of the
the animals and stuff like that yeah and
the rest of the animals all good baby
the one uh White uh whale was doing his
thing you know he looked like he was
having a good time there the Beluga my
son's favorite animal he liked the the
white whale the Lucas or something else
you like the white whale heavy on the
white yeah yep white where's the belugas
I was like what was your favorite he was
like I like the white whale I'm like
okay well don't say that out loud like
didn't you like the Black Sea Lion no
white whale Dad I'm like all right well
a little racism yep you know what the
Narwhal is
the what a narwhal uh-uh bring up a
narwhal
it's Unicorn oh they didn't have that
there look at that thing
they had some fat ass walruses did they
yeah some octopus that looked extra sad
really they're smarter than those killer
whales they're very smart and their
things tiny yeah well you I don't eat
calamari no are you gonna get an octopus
no they're they're bad animal to own why
because they like to hide
so they hide yeah they're awful they
just hide and the only time they come
out is we put fish in there and stuff no
oh no no no no no no no they like to
play hide and go seek 24 7. they do yeah
so if you get one you're like okay well
then and I don't think and you can't
have you can only have one octopus you
can't have anything else in there
because they kill everything they ate
everything everything you can't have
Coral dude they'll [__] [__] up the
clock and crunch it up see crunch it
alone in there just like yeah now an
octopus lives about a year I think no no
certain ones do the other one no they're
so expensive you wouldn't buy an animal
for a year I think they don't have a
long lifespan there's certain ones that
don't three to five
well that's giant giant but that's what
they have at Sea World is that giant one
look at that both wild cats lived
roughly one to five years I know a lot
about things don't ever go no well no
they're sure ones that only live a year
but five years I guess you'd make that
investment three one three years but you
don't want to buy a kid a [__]
octopus and he lives for a year I know
yeah is that a bummer a year I know but
I thought you wanted one of those super
poisonous ones I do until I found out
that all they do is play hide and go
seek and you can't [__] find them my
kids are like what are we doing here
what are we doing well my fish Guy Brian
was like yeah dude this dentist's office
you know I usually I'm an expert he's
legit he's been doing it for 30 years he
goes I know everything is about fish
because this dentist's office these
Koreans chin he goes they wanted an
octopus he's like you don't want an
octopus you're never gonna see it
they're professional hide and go seek
you're never gonna you're never gonna
[__] see him the only time you see
him is when I put fish in and even then
if he knows there's people around he's
gonna wait and then come out and steal
him he's like you don't want it like no
we need an octopus like all right [__]
we're getting an octopus they get this
massive tank 80 grand later
they call hey where the [__] is that was
it that's why I told you you don't see
him right like we never see him he never
comes out you might see his little
tentacle hanging off the side or some
[__] other than that he's not like
floating around smiling and [__] no no
time to see 24 7 [__] really yeah and
then they said that's probably in the
wild too yeah because everything wants
to eat them you never see him sharks
want to eat them everything wants to eat
them you never saw my octopus teacher
did you see that
yes yeah that's why I don't need that's
why I don't need a octopus yeah it's so
[__] up they're so smart so smart and
you know they can feel how you're
feeling when they grab on you if you're
scared if you're Tim if you're sad yeah
dude tell your face yeah dude I don't
know man it really makes you like I saw
this woman I mean
this woman raised a donkey well I got
strong killer whale right yeah those
things are the Tad bunny of the scene
sushi place called hump got shut down
because they were they were serving
dolphin and whale well it's called hump
dolphin and whale it's called they're
giving away dude hump yeah it's a more
gamey version of beef yeah okay because
it's a mammal oh that's right it's a
mammal it's mammal now it lives on fish
but it's pretty delicious yeah
um a lot of mercury apparently
but um
what was I gonna say
this has been octopus talk
I love a nice octopus to watch oh this
donkey this donkey uh saw this woman
raised this Donkey from a baby and she
calls him he had the donkey hadn't seen
her and the donkey comes out and goes
and no it just put his face on her chest
and he was like oh
he was so happy and you go [__] that's a
donkey they have deep feelings yeah so
maybe I won't eat animals anymore well
you don't need God I love cows you don't
need donkey I don't eat donkey but cows
are cute too baby cow's cute as [__]
dude I know
but no they eat donkeys but but when you
think about uh octopus you know there
was a this I forget where this place was
but they they have the video you can
look it up chin I forget where it was
but they had an octopus all the way
across the room all the way across the
room hiding out all the time then across
the way they had some expensive fish
they couldn't figure out why their fish
kept disappearing so they set up cameras
and when they left for the night turned
the lights down the octopus and they're
Escape artists they're Houdini of the
sea they would CR they the the camera
caught this octopus walking across the
[__] room into the other fish tank
eating having his food dipping back out
into his tank closing the lid so they
didn't notice him and you're gonna kill
that thing that's crazy I remember we
tried to look for this one marinara
sauce they're [__] Savages it says
this but doesn't we don't really see it
no no I remember we looked for this
before no but that there's the guy did a
thing that's all just gets out of a jar
oh dude they're insane to keep insane
now that that looks like it's real bud
what happened I mean I couldn't find the
one where it goes across and gets the
fish but I remember it yeah
so it's basically an octopus to start
moving forward he's like sweet jar [__]
yeah octopus are sweet they look cool
too
donkeys and octopuses my two favorite
animals guys
my son's super into lizards that cause
where we buy our exotic fish they have
Exotics does he have a bearded dragon
with two of them yeah two of them but
I'm but they're at the still at the
store right now because we're waiting
because I had to buy the tank oh so
we're not lizards so now you got lizards
you're gonna have to feed them crickets
no just crickets like the worst ass no
crickets are easy my arowanas eat
crickets so I already buy crickets yeah
everyone is eat crazy do they get out no
no no they get out and go to heaven
Cricket Heaven yeah arowanas destroy
them yeah you see legs in the water like
this oh boy they destroy them yeah they
go right for them it's fun to watch your
arowana how's the luxury gone the what
how's the luck streak going what's that
oh good good luck yeah it's been good
luck they're getting bigger too I gotta
upgrade my thing I'm gonna come and uh
dip my finger in there no not for you no
just for the locker it's gonna rub off
yeah catch me like this grabbing it
you eat them yeah cut them up eat them
yeah bumps like you come home I got a
nice Chianti I'm just a nice sauce there
good luck Captain with a bib with a bib
like this
um how are you
no I can't I catch you by the tank with
a fish rod and I'm like take another
fighter than the kid
good luck dude
remember in Game of Thrones when he's
eating the guy so he's eating a sausage
and reek
realizes he hasn't a penis anymore oh
that's right
I do I just put it together they was
eating dick
eating a sausage like that disgusting
[Laughter]
a psycho [__] are you looking
forward to the fight Saturday we're
doing companion for it I'm really
looking forward now that's fighting man
you me Tripoli and uh Cheeto Vera that's
really exciting stupid questions I I
love cheetah Rivera um who doesn't I'm
excited about this I uh who do you got
buddy
I I mean look
you know what
now here's the thing I'll experienced
3-0 against them I know and in in
history whenever especially in UFC
history it never works out for the the
guy who lost when he's trying to get the
belt back in the history of it I don't
care too much about that stuff I'm just
going out there before you know it's
important I still have busy women
by either finish in the first two rounds
or decision
my problem is that thing I can't get
around is that Alex Pera is bigger
stronger and I believe Alex can just cut
the ring off close distance
get flat-footed and start banging and I
don't know what Izzy does about it he
didn't do that until late in the rounds
last time right a few things to do it
early on this thing laying around they
went like this they went hey we're done
playing around yeah what we're doing is
not working yeah because he was losing
go and yes now go and go and punch him
in the face a lot now remember this B he
he tried that in the in the first fight
just not too long ago I think it was
December last year Matt Square Garden he
tried that and if there was 10 seconds
left in that first round he would have
got finished
because he got caught after the Bell
though no no no
no no no he was on queer Street dude yes
but I think he got hit no no uh I think
he did there's more punches after but he
was wobbling right but I think because
he was already throwing when the bills
yeah I think Alex which which is legal
yeah which is legal but Alex went I'm
done I don't think so no no we can play
this because the Bell didn't ring you
see it yeah but we can't play it on air
obviously but let me look at it I think
you're gonna find that I'm no I just
watched it be yeah
and watch this because I watched that
and I think
hold on
um yeah I don't know though so you're
you're thinking that Izzy will find a
way to deal with that Onslaught with
that power Izzy could right he he could
hold on
um
[Applause]
oh this is the finish of Izzy though oh
yeah come on people think that was a
controversial stoppage yeah none of
that's it just go to the full video
well I don't have the
[Applause]
the full video
those low kicks are a [__] right
no not for Izzy the little kids to
nothing no he's a professional kickboxer
yeah but
uh so but the point is is we'll deal
with the election it's too much of a
hold up yeah but the point is he's got
it with no sound God while we're talking
yeah I'll do it the point is is that uh
the time that they've spent together
even in kickboxing the two fights before
this and then the one fight in the UFC
Izzy's won the majority of the rounds
yeah he it's just Alex Pierre hits so
[__] hard I know there it is
and he landed a big knee see that see
see but he was wobbling way before that
right you're right hey apologize
I apologize though right right you're
right Bob yeah of course I'm right you
know what
you know what you know I'm rooting for
Izzy you know I want him to win badly
yeah just because I just think he's
awesome and but I also normally we love
Izzy I'm root for his I think he is he a
straight up heart of hearts I think as
he gets it done
but none of it matters because I'll
experience future is that like
heavyweight is he's gonna be at
middleweight that's right and the only
thing people are doing is keeping the
The Throne warm for uh Hamza you think
Hamza beats Izzy yes with his wrestling
or what yeah
yeah because Alex doesn't zero exactly
zero right so that's why oxygen is good
to light heavy weight because Who's the
champion light heavyweight not a
wrestler Jamal Hill straight Striker
that's right and he doesn't have the
pedigree that Alex Pierre does I think
our experience can be championed which
he already is so at middleweight and
Champion light heavyweight uh yeah but
there are there are there are guys at
205 there are certain Russian guys can't
remember that guy's name the other guys
that are gonna y'all can wrestle and the
other guy the uh Yuri there are guys who
are going to take him to the ground uh I
think I think I think yeah there are too
many guys who just really understand
wrestling none of that matters yeah I'm
saying that there's better matchups for
him because after uh Izzy he gets diceye
the rest of that division can all
grapple all of them yeah and then Hamza
it's it's either in the next few months
he gets a title shot it's just a matter
of time because that's and he's a better
Grappler name at light heavyweight or
middleweight yeah so he's there so at
light heavyweight look Yuri Striker
Jamal Hill Champion Striker Monica bed
is gonna be a nightmare John's gonna be
a nightmare racket he's coming mouth
injury but racket when he's back Striker
so bracket uh yiri and Jamal Hill all
great matchups for PIRA Anthony Smith
fun matchup he's a striker you know cry
laugh Striker Johnny Walker peer Striker
osmere pure Striker Paul Craig Grappler
nightmare but he probably won't get the
shot at him uh soon yeah but you look at
that you're right look how fun that is
who can strike but also wrestle he's and
that's that's a pain in the ass yeah but
yawn and him went to a draw yes now um
let's get back to Izzy and I I so so you
think I mean I I forgot about that Izzy
is you know he was winning that fight
get it done it's easy of course but Izzy
was winning that fight dude all the way
up to that final blow he just can't
afford to get caught like that and
that's his thing is he can get up the
first three rounds and then make it very
boring the fourth and fifth just right
and just write it down that might happen
yes I think he either is he knocks him
out or wins I'm taking Israel out of
Sonya yeah oh you're taking Israel out
of Sanya now to be fair and uh what's in
PD Carroll who does that show PT Carroll
who does that show with Ariel I guess he
has an interview come out today he was
saying uh in the interview he interviews
Izzy's coach who's one of the best uh
Minds in the game and he said he went
into that interview thinking as he was
going to win but talking to the coach
he's like no I think Pierre's gonna win
because he's saying PIRA is the greatest
knockout artist ever in UFC history he
goes because fundamentally because
that's when they watch tape they're
trying to break it down like figure out
his power forward where he gets from he
goes none of it makes sense the way how
heavy he's on his front foot his powers
from God man he's the hardest hitting
guy in the UFC of all time yes nightmare
which is scary yes yeah really that's
right that's why he'll he'll be Champion
like heavyweight no doubt this guy I
mean him versus Jamal Hill's ridiculous
fight
I mean I you know I don't think Jamal
Hill doesn't have the uh
he just doesn't have the patterns he's
not as high level as Striker no I think
I think a para breaks him down right
away and says I see what you're doing
and those were look at him that's
inspiring a Chinese boxer Champion
that's like six six two nineties yes
crazy Beast
he's just a [__] beast he's been
doing this for so long
man if anybody can it's easy
if anybody can Rush card is tasty too
Gilbert Burns Mazda dolls yeah I mean I
got burns on that only because he's a
huge favorites become too wealthy too
he's got other [__] going on whenever
you have about this shit's going on
toddler stuff whenever you guys it's
really hard to but then also maswell
said if I lose my last fight whenever I
hear them that ain't good yeah good for
him that means yes he can move on to
other stuff but also as for the fight
game goes when you have all those other
options it's not good you got Holland
over positive easy yeah hold on mops the
floor with him uh Adrian Yana is Rob
font that's the fight finally right
I don't know anything about that yeah I
know you don't uh you're right we talked
about this yes yep I know nothing about
it of course you know uh Rose a junior
Christian Rodriguez Good roses Jr is the
18 year old long face
oh yeah
the longest face but he's a superstar
yeah Superstar but that's not an easy
fight for him I think he wins via
decision but that's a tough fight for
him yeah
but go back to Ryan yeah Joe Pfeiffer
he's a Savage why is that the fight of
the night Rob fought adrianes oh man
it's the first like so Adrian's on
defeated in the UFC it's the first real
test for uh Adrian he's been mopping the
floor with everybody rob font top five
who's the guy that Rob Farm fought the
last guy fat Cheeto all right
he got beat up really really bad
it's a rough fight for him yeah Cheeto
Jose was a tough one before that he was
Merkin dude so so Rob finds one of the
best there is it's a very tough fight
for Giannis this is where we're gonna
see if he's actually a contender
it's gonna be like an amazing
spot that's the thing Adrian has it he's
that guy who hasn't really been tested
what'd you say didn't he fight Joe Kelly
laugh yeah yeah Tony Kelly yeah but so
you look at us a lot of those guys
aren't in the UFC anymore that was the
performance night performance tonight
performance night fight the night
performance of the night damn Savage wow
good great kid too you should watch his
highlights Brian his highlights yeah
before companion I'll send you some
fights on them you'll blow your mind the
kid's [__] really talented
this is a great it's a great just
overall MMA fight but both their boxing
is ridiculous yeah ridiculous High High
Caliber both of them
Kevin Holland needs when he's coming off
two losses we got Kevin Gaston still at
it
Kelvin Kelvin why it's funny how people
what is the preliminary prelim card is
it just where your ranking is and that's
what do you mean where where they they
take a guy Calvin gaslin who's been
around he's a name he's the name he's
the main event on the prelims so right
they always put a big name on the
prelims right in order to sell more so
it's not like it's not a and that's a
good thing that when you're a fighter if
you're the name on the prelim it's fine
like not really it sucks if you're
killing a little bit of excuse to fight
for a title yeah but they'll just use
your name to sell more paper Michelle
Waterson change your name to Gomez she
got married
she was married burchard Joe Pfeiffer is
a great fight Carl Williams Chase
Sherman
Cynthia calvillo used to be you know we
thought she was the next thing at straw
weight we thought she was the next champ
yeah you know you don't want to be in
the prelimsby yeah no and usually
they'll do like a young guy there to see
how he does and then they'll get you the
main card but like for that Rose of
Junior to kick off the the main
pay-per-views insane at 18 18 years old
that long face dude 18. I know nuts now
his face some of that is not from
fighting some of that is just the way
his nose was I think but look at his
ears
excuse me fighting though he looks like
a Spanish conqueror yeah he looks like I
think he had a cleft palate he was born
with a cleft palate so his nose and his
his uh his so his nose and his lip were
attached when he was born yeah so you
know what I'm saying so I'm saying that
that's not necessarily from getting
punched in the face that's just the way
his nose is and he has like if you hear
him speak he has a bit of a some sort of
a speech impediment type of thing yeah
yeah
now now um what is his fighting since he
was like six he's been fine since he was
two years old it's crazy
Habsburg jaw it's like a
thing oh this is real Condition it's
like a thing in your family history yeah
wow his brother looks completely
different though does he yeah that's
that's not an easy life man for that kid
that's what sucks I also think that like
it's a little bit like the um you got
that kid and then you've got uh who's
our boy Aaron Pico and these kids have
been boxing since they were really young
and taking shots to the Head
and different for him because you don't
have the same background as Pico he
knows national champion boxer yeah but
he what I've noticed that he goes out
real quick and sometimes you can get
that that he goes different because you
straight up scrap in boxing right Rosa
has it I would never have I don't think
that's a good idea yeah no no at all
right no although canel same thing
worked out for him boxers are really
really careful though in those gyms with
those kids no no they are actually
though because the way you are raised
they they everything's really controlled
no like the main thing is don't get hit
no those no no those those Mexican gyms
you know Canelo probably had a thousand
fights by time to improve yeah yeah
everyone's doing the same [__] certain
people are different
also mma's different yeah you hit an MMA
it's a little different than in boxing
it's just different and some people just
are like canel's made for it
some people aren't in Pico you know
Pico's on a winning streak now though
yes Greg Jackson [__] yeah that's great
yeah he's destroying dudes now man he's
he's just awesome I I always wanted he
was such a he was wrestling on the
international circuit at 16 years old
he's just a prodigy so he started off
rough and then he won one two three four
five six he lost his last one against
German Kennedy but he won six in a row
that's because his shoulder popped out
and yeah
and they try to yank it back I know oh I
know
oh yeah he's a Savage though all right
he's still doing the damn thing okay
still hope for him good
what do you got Jen
all right you guys are talking about
Stormy Daniels and oh where are we ever
you know her views on YouPorn have gone
through the roots I checked it out I
want to see what this is what slayed the
trumpet it's record-breaking bump I hope
she's making money off this absolutely
not sir no they said that she might I
don't know how it works with PornHub but
I think she does get some sort of like I
assume she has only like streaming with
me I assumes she she has only fans I
would imagine too yeah her own like
website
I wonder if she's doing any kind of a
dance circuit oh she is oh she is all
the Trump Sports got and Sierra cheetahs
where the [__] it's going
so it jumped 32 400 percent well that's
a lot
yeah you get the president check it out
think of Marilyn Monroe is on there went
during JFK you checked that out I have
to check it out
I'll tell you what I want to see what
all the fuss was about
I'll tell you it's a better option than
you part I'll just put that out there
better option than you yeah
and you guys mentioned that she has to
pay 122 000 in like uh lawyer fees
because her that information suit was
she lost her defamations yeah that's
Trump yeah
um all right by the way Venice Whole
Foods
uh two days ago
we've been there a thousand times
two people shot and killed guy came up
and went bang bang in Venice yeah they
think it was a drug thing so it looked
like the Whole Foods right off Abby
Kelly yeah
oh the rose one that one's a little
dicey e
right in the [__] uh two shot and
killed in parking lot of Whole Foods
about us why isn't this something shot
and killed two people near our taco
stand that taco stands right off the
Venice Boulevard I've gotten tacos there
you bet your sweet ass yeah
um wow in part a lot of CVS Pharmacy she
was in the shooting occurred at 9 15 P.M
Monday in the parking lot Jesus Christ
man wow I've been there one million
times I do
so someone just approached them and shot
them yeah I think it looks like they
think it was a hit
in Venice gang related
yeah they think they were both homeless
well that's not Gang Related no but they
think it was a drug thing but I don't
know let me guess the homeless didn't
pay him a homeless guy didn't pay them
you know either way it's terrible my
thing is like when they can't find the
guy right away like this a lot of times
it's like
that that person probably lives is
living under a bridge
Jesus Christ yeah
alrighty bless us CBS no that was a
different one
in 2020. that's a lot of stuff going on
CBS is right across the street
my dad's in Venice right now take the
kids and see them tonight for dinner not
anymore
I tell you it's outrageous I am outraged
we're doing Uber Eats [__] you know oh
yeah
scary yeah what else you got Jen so this
one actually happened not too far from
here this is at uh God damn it but no
one died but this is a crazy woman in
her 20s trying to steal a woman's an
older lady's purse and then took try to
still try to steal her car afterwards
let's play for you
that's her trying to steal the car yep
where are they at Costco
looks like a CVS I can't tell
[Music]
well shoot the worst Crook in the world
I know
she can't drive for [__] but she's
hitting everybody
I like how this lady's just sitting
there
won't you break the window dude
it's really hard to break a window
[Music]
hits that person's car and the other one
I mean she is just if you're just
listening this lady is straight Monster
Jam in the entire Costco parking lot in
a Hyundai Sonata
she get away no they catch her and
what's cool is like there's a woman that
actually caught it oh my God
why does she want the car that bad she's
crazy she's probably yeah probably drug
addict or something but then here's some
of the
what I do is I jump in the air and I
kick through the windshield and knock
her out but then you might die right
because she's gonna oh yeah
but see a woman actually helped with red
hair on the ground
it's hard not to give her a couple shots
in the back of the head for that oh man
you're not gonna kill somebody give her
a Kirby am I right yeah but she's also
just a mess I like how that one lady was
just standing there like what in the
[__]
years in prison after calling
ex-girlfriend over 800 times
why is that five years because it's also
it's like uh it's uh what do you call it
when you're abusing them online it's
kind of yeah but that's
cyber stalking some do a cyber crime
yeah but 800 calls in two days that's
400 a day average so I'd assume he was
using some sort of app to keep calling
right or is he doing no he's just crazy
and then he would he would do stuff like
post stuff on social media to like get
her to like bad stuff as well so he's
yeah he's giving her a really hard time
he also sent her a thousand texts over
several months you social media post to
embarrass certain interfere with their
livelihood yeah
I think it's I think it's appropriate to
put him in jail for five years because I
don't think anybody's gonna miss him is
that is that too much everybody the
charges come back to his face first the
charges hold on the charges come after a
man in the UK earliest month was
sentenced to 17 weeks imprisonment for
harassing a BBC presenter over Facebook
yeah
he looks like uh he's made the wrong
choices
I don't like how skinny you guys go to
the same Barber right same Barber I'm
not happy with how skinny his neck is
and how he says eyes aren't just pitch
black yes eyes aren't off oblong
everything's wrong here he's like hmm
yeah and that's his ex so they dated for
at least some time
he lives in a hole yeah something's
mentally awful yeah just look at him
yeah things don't no
this popped up as well uh I don't know
much about this but this is terrible so
Jake Shields yeah tweeted this he goes
to uh yesterday Jay goes my friend was
stabbed in San Francisco and died he had
two daughters one of you guys gonna do
something I didn't know it was this guy
so this guy started Cash Out is it like
a building
that's not my good friend was killed
last night while walking in San
Francisco
attack
wow
I didn't realize San Francisco's that
bad no I I don't know
terrible oh San Francisco's awful [__]
yeah awful yeah only 43 years old had
two little girls
oh no
um going back to the fish stuff this is
what uh Georgie found
so if someone if you can yeah someone
took a flash photo of this giant
aquarium and this fish commits suicide
by running into the glass head first or
maybe he thought or like it scared him
or something
boom
see right there
don't be mad I don't think he might do
that yes yeah like even with like home
aquariums we turn the lights on they go
they don't like it it's not natural so I
never do that I turn the the house
lights on first and then slow ease them
into it boom let me maybe just couldn't
see him freak the [__] out from the
flash that's what happened yeah the
other fish like Jesus Christ Craig
and also when you're fishing these these
lures that flash so it's just
instinctual too they might be trying to
go after bait or something I don't know
but this tragic incident all right well
so you can't really do flash anymore
it's wrong word yeah we just talked
about two people getting shot
that's tragic this isn't good to also
don't lose your flash what the [__] you
doing also I can't stand when people
take pictures of just if you're not in
the picture what are you gonna do with
that dude who are you gonna show that to
check out this fish I saw it in Long
Beach people videotape I'd be like can I
Google it [__] you
I can't I can't deal with it
um we talked about Takashi 69 being beat
up at a gym so these are the guys and I
guess this older dude he's like the
leader of Latin Kings or something like
that oh oh well now the guy on the right
was like hey can you meet the Lloyd
Christmas Cut yes
hey can you give me the simple Jack
haircut before I go to prison yeah the
other guys have some strong beards very
Muslim looking yeah that's what I was
yeah but I guess Lion King's is a Latin
gang so yeah
they're the Latin gang they don't mess
with those and he was he's a leader in
the Latin this guy right here apparently
wow is Elite maybe one of the leaders I
don't know I think he had a tattoo of a
I think he had or was talking about that
who had the Crocs on so you don't want
to [__] with those Scott cheeks not as
good point he goes just imagine you have
nothing to do with the situation feeling
obligated to make it your business very
weird yeah
you're getting the right though well
these guys are definitely going to be
doing some time
and all their boys are in there
yeah I don't know if these guys are gang
members but for sure they were saying
this person is so anyway well I'd
imagine the other guys the same last
name I think they're Brothers
are they I mean come on
they must be ready okay yeah they got in
the rights the outline yeah the simple
Jack haircut yeah
like hey Anthony you don't want to just
shave it they gave me they gave him the
what for they gave him a good old a good
old booting with Crocs yes and here's
the thing though it's like you know that
the cameras are rolling so you you know
some things you told me these guys don't
make good decisions yeah that's them uh
before the attack and that's one of the
bald-headed guys who know he's right
here dude
and he's calling his homies
and they come pretty fast they're
probably like getting you know froze up
Froyo or something wow and they're just
gonna go we're gonna beat him up and
like he has Crocs on look at this so
that's so the older guy calls the other
then where's the simple Jack haircut
he's coming soon no mask no nothing I'm
just gonna go in there and beat him up
we can't go in Mass B there he is
oh the leader they both have Crocs and
then they then one switches he's like
you're gonna get my good stomping shoes
on
insane rough looking cats yeah if I saw
them just doing that I would be like oh
something's gonna happen
yo you're also working at Planet Fitness
yeah so you're not gonna be like I
better get on this case wow I don't know
somebody's about to get [__] up chimps
wow just gave him a the what for
all right so before I get to the main Uh
current event on this one this is a
little bit of background this person is
named I think Dylan Mulvaney
she's transitioned and documented on
Tick Tock and got famous for transitions
yeah like really famous apparently yeah
originally followers yes and then so she
had posted something about uh freeing
the or something about being okay with
the Bulge a bulge movement because she's
wearing these shorts
it's probably it's probably better if I
just play the video first
she's also the one sponsored by Bud
Light she's on it has her own Bud Light
can that's where the that's pretty
fascinating so let me play this first
before being a girl Round of Applause
for the makeup and I wore this outfit
shopping today and I thought that these
might be my new shopping shorts but I
was walking around and everyone was a
series and I was like oh okay what's
going on and they were all staring
directly at my crotch and I went oh I
forgot that my crotch doesn't look like
other women's crotches sometimes because
mine doesn't look like a little Barbie
pocket and I thought okay Dylan you have
some options here no Dylan they're
staring at huge [__]
s buying looser fitting items
item talk which is gonna have to be a
whole other video but it's very painful
and involved about
or number three
like this and we all just normalize with
bulges sometimes we're coming up on
bikini season baby and you might see a
bulge or two so no woman lies
see I like him for her that's okay we're
not gonna stare at their crotches while
they're wearing their little shopping
he's got a great sense of humor or she
does
thank you love you
see that okay let me just say something
about Dylan Minnie this is an adult who
decided to go all the way or do what
what well not all the way no but do
what's where the Bulge goes do what
they're doing I got no problem if an
adult like that wants to do it it's part
of the American Experience very funny
silly the whole thing do your thing I I
always say I draw the line when you
start talking about kids you start
talking about gender affirming care you
start doing that with kids you can go
[__] yourself you become my enemy but
I'm going to support any adult who like
this is a colorful character
funny entertaining and look you want to
do that just expression I mean it is
what it is you're not saying you have to
be comfortable with it I think yeah I
think we're going on a limbs saying that
everyone's staring at her crotch I don't
think everyone's well no oh my God this
is somebody who's always content right
always doing stuff always coming that's
the reason yeah yeah well what else is
uh so anyway so when this happened uh
Senator Marsha Blackburn yeah had
commented on it
uh hold on
Dylan Mulvaney Joe Biden and the radical
left wing lunatics want to make this
absurdity normal and then I Caitlyn
Jenner replied to it
go back up can you go up not only not
only uh did Jenner
but she also doubled down on her
statement by following what there's a
difference between acceptance and
tolerance and normalizing exposing your
genitals in a public way in a public
space I did not support that at all in
the slightest Dylan congrats you're
trans with a penis and then he there's a
difference okay uh um hold on
people online with me they came to my
paintings and point out Jenner Jenner's
misgendering or maybe as well can I read
it hold on I'm trying to find the he
part as well as the hypocrisy of Jenner
a fellow trans woman making those
comments
you called her a he that's the issue you
don't see that keep going I had a fit if
someone called you a he in a public eye
all right thanks AJ Christie something
he goes he's talking about his penis
when they said the Bulge somebody's like
nobody's exposing themselves Jesus
Christ oh yeah he's talking about his
PPS yeah
and then
anyways after all this stuff happened
Dylan made a video about Caitlyn Jenner
as well but then uh Kid Rock
who normally likes Bud Lights because so
that yeah he started promoting for Bud
Light another March Madness no no yeah
start promoting uh Bud Light signed
um her yeah her face is on the camera
yeah yeah and then so this is Kid Rock's
response
grandpa is feeling a little frisky today
a
let me uh say something to all you would
be as clear and concise as possible
[__] Bud Light and [__] Anheuser-Busch
have a terrific day
everybody has a right to express
themselves as they will I'm surprised
that is that on YouTube did they take
that down or I don't think that's on
YouTube that was on his social media
that's on Instagram
but that's her
promoting online you know bud light's
trying to get their name out there
what do you think of that it's kind of
quiet in this room uh it's a confusing
time in general it's not confusing I
think Bud Light was completely missed
the mark on this I especially with their
demo
that's like Dodge or Ford I'm not saying
that you know Dodge is going electric
your brother just told me no I know yeah
after that that's why they did that that
crazy one yeah everyone's headed that
way but the thing is with this it's like
it's not that I I don't I don't give a
[__] we're addressed to get your big
dick out I don't care dude yeah but I
think if you're Dodge for these American
Staples they're really missing the mark
when they assume their demo is on board
with this and they might not even be
anti-trans they might just not be that's
not their thing no it's ASG so they're
not what that is no but they're not
going to support it so Bud Lights can
take a hit man no no so so these
companies have to show what's called
good citizenship environmental uh it's
so it's a is it ESG
um environmental uh yeah ESG social
governance social governance so there's
a lot of pressure on all these companies
to environmental social and good
governance corporate governance
um design embed equity and stuff like
that that's generally value for all
organizations stakeholders no that
that's why you see all these
corporations they have to have a
commercial with a trans person or black
person Eminem got rid of the dresses
right so this is what all these
corporations are trying to do and
there's a lot of being dick well the
majority of the majority out of their
mind when I saw this I went you're gonna
get a boycott there's other ways to do
it and I think the boycott comes from
more than just bigotry I think the
boycott comes no the fact that you're
trying to tell them no realizes that
this is normal and that gender is a
construct I personally disagree that
gender is a construct most of America
personally believe that your gender and
biology are aligned that's what I
believe that's that's how I identify you
can say whatever you want you can call
me a bigot I I don't agree that because
somebody says they're a woman they're a
woman because they feel like a woman
they're a woman I don't agree with that
I don't think being a woman or a man
I believe in science I believe that
gender and and biology have a
correlation I'm allowed to talk about
that and I don't think I bet the problem
is let me just go keep going because the
prod the people get react if I I say
that I can be banned I can be Shadow
banned I can be considered a a bigot I
can be considered Prejudice I can be
consider all these things that will hit
me with all these labels and I'm
ostracized that's what I react to that's
why I go [__] you too like I'm not going
to be more you don't like it when it's
when it's forced on you
then I think that's weird life talk to
my children and the transgender the myth
and the Mark's like no no I don't care
what you do dude whatever makes you
happy yeah you can do whatever you want
yeah to your point when you start doing
it enforce it on kids and force it on us
we're like no you have got to look at my
ball it's like no I don't well well
Dylan milfanie is a different thing that
person seems like a lot of fun and and
funny that's a different thing I don't
care about that that's the individual
what I have a problem with is what
they're really trying to do what the
left is really trying to do is they are
trying to enforce their ideology on my
children on our schools and how we
educate people and they're enforcing it
everywhere so you cannot lib you cannot
speak your mind and they are also very
very very involved in censorship that's
what I object to and that's I think what
what kid rock is saying yeah you're
trying to make this normal I disagree
it's absurd and Bud Light supporting it
yeah good luck seems like oh they're
screwed good luck to that really miss
the market there are people that'll
never drink Bud Light again
they're like what are you doing no
there's there's
what else catch in it's like Gillette
you saw what happened with Gillette when
they did that anti-man campaign yeah
yeah way to go dumbasses uh I just saw
this yesterday yeah two days ago so but
Marlon Wayans dad passed away and then
marlawynne's found out during between
sets so he did his first set found out
the news and then he continued on to do
the second set afterwards and then
Marlon wins is a real Pro yeah and he
ended up crying talking about it on
stage afterwards and he's at Flappers
yeah in Burbank
this is just a clip of it I don't know
if I should play a clip of a comedy
though yeah we can hear him
I said you did all this mama and you
only made one crackhead
he's awesome he's a good guy yeah he's
funny I auditioned for him and his
brother that's a bummer
yeah man
they're a good family
yeah so they're a tight family you guys
talked about this a while ago we never
got to cover it though you guys want to
discuss this at all
so I first when I read oh she's great
too she's in that uh uh the [__] [__]
on Netflix yeah so I when I read this be
like I was like um somebody she goes
somebody made a sexual comment and I was
like oh man you're being a baby and then
I and then I hold on yeah hold on that's
why I said I was like Jesus Christ
that's not good and I looked at what the
guy said guy comes over here so on let's
let's tell the fans what's going on here
so yeah she but on my b-day last year a
well-known actor walked up to me at the
party and said
I'm telling that I've jacked off to you
so many times she wrote I was shocked by
that like I get that because at first
when she said a well-known actor made a
sexual comment to me I was like I
thought he came up was like you look
great tonight and she's like wow dude
right then you see that and I'm like I
jacked off to you so many times hey man
that's [__] up yeah well this is
creepy like I get it I get her feeling
of like going what what is this like
that's fantastic did you say who the
actor was no she can't but no but I
guess just started from this post first
because she did like a nude post or
whatever and then apparently the actor
that she's talking about initially said
like I love your acting work like you
gave her praise and then at the party he
said I've jacked off to you yeah like
like so I think the the appetizer was I
love your acting and by the way I yeah I
yank it to you not not first of all
that's super rude and not genuinely it's
not manly or genuinely and I just think
it's [__] flirty at all
that actor
[Music]
but I'm saying I assume he was hammered
and to go up to a girl you don't know
and go hey what's up great job I have
Jack talk to me so many times now now
you can't do that like that's that's and
and by the way this is that's not
acceptable
back then or now like back then even in
the 30s they're like hey if you take it
easy
punched in the face yeah it's weird you
don't say that to a woman you [__]
learn some it's what we do man it's
1942. I was like no no even the 40s
weird well learn respect and manners you
morons but also out of here has that
ever worked for whoever this [__] is he
sucks I've jacked up to you so many
times like oh really I was with can I I
was with uh I I interviewed a porn star
and her husband in Vegas
um on my podcast a long time ago like
this is when I met you I think it was
the with the weekend I met you
and uh she was I can't remember her name
famous porn star she did Howard Stern a
lot
and I was I I had met a guy there and
the guy I didn't know very well came up
and goes he goes
write to her he goes I've glazed my
belly so many times watching oh Glacier
oh she went and she went I feel thank
you and I was like oh that that one
right there which one the the second one
down yeah the second one yeah
yes her Tabitha Stevens that's it that's
me yeah she's famous and I was like oh
long face big dick long face they did
yeah I don't know that's uh was named
American long Facebook did
yeah it was very Blaze my belly I glazed
my belly I was like oh
I've jacked up so many times sir please
God damn I wonder who it was what if
it's someone super well she's like it
was Harrison Ford yeah
what if it's just some huge old school
just some dummy it has to be somebody
super old school yeah
she had a bunch of stuff taken out I
think she had she had a tough time of it
she had a tough time
I don't know there she is with Ron
Germany I think that's a difference we
are not doing well never mind that is
her well he his case got thrown out
because he has such bad dementia I think
he's thrown out he's still in prison
he's [__] it no he uh he's not he has
to bring that up Jim yeah such bad
demand she had to no they said he was in
fit to stand trial it's not thrown out
there's like 60 cases of food I know but
I think
he's committed to a mental health
facility he didn't go to jail
he just did not competent to stand trial
but I mean
so he didn't
he was he was putting uh he's so unfit
for sex crimes yeah he can't so
committed to a state Mentor how creepy
looking to see
I know big deal horror movie
yeah
not a good uh it does not end well but
not that's how
it's the end of Boogie night it's not
depressing that is I was shut off before
it gets in to the end I would shut it
off but I don't know how many women came
forward about him a good amount
a 34. that's a lot
yeah all 34 can't be lined right no that
was like the Cosby thing like all
eighties together a bunch of women with
the same story you got a problem yeah
almost positive 34 just vitamin 34
charges with uh 21 women over two
decades it's a lot I think you saw 21
women over two decades wow 30 sexual 30.
so now he just goes to that mental and
student dies there yeah
I mean he looks like he's having a
[__] terrible time as is I mean I
don't know yeah he's he's uh
not well no no
well is that a chin well let's just do
there's an older one but this is a happy
one okay
I saw this haul ago so a daughter her
father needed a kidney and he said
there's no way you're gonna do it for me
she she did it behind his back and gave
her his get or gave her her kidney oh
wow gave her him her kidney yeah
struggle City I know dude your chin has
trouble speaking I do I do
so he didn't want to do it but no she
did it behind closed doors I was like
got your kidney it's mine yeah so that's
a good happy ending that's cool man
who should end on bringing up uh Ron
Jeremy height of his
pounding days with a big dick well he
could suck his own dick you know that
yeah yeah that's how you know he's
mentally crazy he could suck his own
dick you know he'll let you know too
very flexible spine he was the Hedgehog
were we ever around him I've been around
once or twice look at him when he was
younger
look at him there before he gained all
that weight look at that hairy chest wow
before he was in shape
good-looking dude yeah he really was and
it just went so South look at him
and where's the giant guy look at that
picture in black and white
in his underwear with the ladies of this
one eyeball with his weiner
yeah no idea what that is yeah he just
got ugly over the years there's him
young younger okay
but he's great looking he looks like the
gay aliens kind of a 70s
70s star
God what a nightmare
but he was still [__] even with the
yeah he just let himself go look at him
there Axel Rose
but Ron he just
kept eating yeah he's here and yeah
Father Time punished him yeah
and then that's him now Jesus Christ oh
that's not a good look you don't think
he's trying to suck his own wee-wee wow
look at that just the end of everything
yeah that's not informed yeah that's
called that's called the tragic life
punishment holy [__]
poof not the way you want to go out good
well I'll try and suck my own Arena on
stage in Atlanta next week Thursday
Friday Saturday next weekend next
Thursday Friday Saturday Atlanta why oh
no this weekend we have fighting next
weekend next weekend next Thursday
Friday Atlanta then June 2nd through the
4th La Jolla comedy store and then June
15th through the 25th I'm over in Europe
starting with Belfast ending in Dublin
the rest of there's London Cardiff
Manchester it's all available are you
going to documentboy.com I don't know
man bring bring a camera person you'd be
crazy not to maybe we'll see how it goes
I mean I did last time hey I got it dude
I got you buddy
um yeah we'll see I usually hire so in
each City yeah that's what I do instead
of flying one guy around fly somebody
around no this is a nightmare I like
that hey you should pay for a nice
chicken fly somebody
uh Helium Comedy Club I'll see you April
20th to the 22nd Comedy Zone Port
Charlotte uh May four five and six and
then uh God look at that Ontario Improv
July 27th to the 29th a long time away
huh oh yeah all right look at that 2024.
oh I got May mace busy for me yeah
you should probably get those dates up
probably get those dates up yeah it
doesn't look busy at all
right vicaban Saturday 7 P.M Pacific
live think more YouTube UFC 287 Brian
Collins Sam tripley Cheeto Vera and
myself live on thick boy YouTube UFC 287
cobass fight campaign tune in all right
love you guys see ya